I've just arrived at the most dangerous
place to be a pedestrian in the U.S
US 19 in Newport Richie Florida on the
state's Gulf Coast
a group of urban planners looked at the
entire U.S roadway Network and
identified 60 pedestrian fatality hot
spots one thousand meter corridors where
pedestrian deaths are most common and
this 1 000 meter stretch topped their
list 17 fatal crashes here in a 16-year
study window
pedestrian fatalities in the U.S have
been creeping up in the past decade
thanks mostly to the way road
infrastructure favors cars Above All
Else
and nowhere is that more clear than
right here
north to south down Florida's Gulf Coast
and bisects the small community of
Newport Richie cutting off its downtown
from its Coastal features which means
traveling east to west or vice versa
requires you to cross it it's a type of
roadway that would feel familiar to
Americans car culture is visible
everywhere from the volume of drivers to
the businesses alongside it
and a long U.S 19 drivers are moving
fast the posted speed limit on this
stretch is 45 miles per hour but driving
speeds appear to be much faster than
that
Traffic Safety experts will tell you
that speed is one of the most important
factors in pedestrian safety
a street design Rapport established that
traveling up to 15 miles per hour
drivers have a wide peripheral vision
they only need 25 feet to come to a full
stop and the risk of fatality if they
hit someone is two percent
once drivers are traveling over 40 miles
per hour their peripheral view Narrows
they require more room to stop and the
risk of fatality claims to 85 percent
enforcing speed limits can only do so
much the built environment as we call it
is sending a message that this is for
high-speed travel Robert Schneider LED
The Pedestrian safety study that found
that 97 of the roadways with high
pedestrian fatalities had multiple Lanes
at its widest US 19 spans eight Lanes
which allows cars to pass and move
faster than if they were stuck behind
another car in a single Lane and the
road is straight as an arrow no curves
that would nudge drivers to take it slow
the type of businesses along US 19
support a car first fast driving
environment big box stores and strip
malls that sit far away from the road
with large parking lots in between
and billboards displayed up high for an
audience of fast drivers rather than at
human scale
arterial roads like US 19 not quite a
street but not quite a highway we're
built to keep this high-speed traffic
off of nearby residential neighborhoods
but this type of sprawling development
grew along arterial roads creating a
dangerous mix of car-centric design with
the possibility that pedestrians
cyclists or public transit users would
want to access these business centers
and it explains why arterial roads only
make up 13 percent of U.S roadways but
are the site of 59 of pedestrian deaths
[Music]
now let's relate that to us 19's
pedestrian design or lack thereof
not everyone can or wants to drive but
they still have to get to where they're
going I walk along U.S 19 about three or
four times a week 20 from work it's a
lot cheaper than thinking about I also
crossing the uh the crosswalk someone
was turning and this Buck right into me
I had a few bumps because you know some
cracked risk I have a hearing disability
which causes severe vertigo and issues
with balance so it's not wise to drive
every single day
I am
afraid of either getting
bumped or yelled at or honked at or cut
off
every day
[Music]
as a pedestrian trying to cross the road
I'd have to choose between this
crosswalk or this one which is nearly
950 meters away that's a 30 or 40 minute
walk a distance so far that it
encourages risky jaywalking there's a
better term for that it turns out costs
are the location where there's no signal
in the profession we tend to try to say
that jaywalk is a term that was
developed by the auto interests in the
early 1900s to essentially shame people
who were crossing in the middle of the
block which had been okay socially prior
to the 1920s 1930s the sidewalks are
constantly interrupted by the curb cuts
into parking lots which introduce more
opportunities to interact with a moving
car without a signal I first tried this
crosswalk waited for 10 minutes only to
find out it didn't work so I tried the
next Crossing Robert Schneider told me
that the longer you wait at a crosswalk
the more pedestrians are incentivized to
cross before the signal finally one once
you do cross you have to Traverse the
length of the eight Lanes which puts us
19 in the company of 70 percent of the
hot spot roadways in Robert Schneider
study that Force pedestrians to cross
five or more Lanes
and all of this is so much more
treacherous when there is less light
[Music]
there's a concept in urbanism called
Safety in numbers the more pedestrians
there are in an environment the safer it
is to be one there aren't many
pedestrians along US 19 which makes the
high number of fatalities even more
alarming the lower the median household
income in a neighborhood the more common
it is for pedestrian fatalities to occur
there
and that's because bad street design and
arterial roads like US 19 are more
likely to exist in those communities
improving pedestrian design would invite
more people to walk making it safer for
people who have no other choice
Florida Transportation officials are
spending Millions to improve this
stretch of U.S 19. like reducing the
speed limit adding more crosswalks
adding more lights and delaying green
lights at intersections
the mayor of Newport Richie told me he
favors adding pedestrian and cyclist
Bridges here to get people off the road
entirely these are expensive Solutions
and unpopular among drivers but not
nearly as hard as the long-term goal
which is undoing Decades of car-centric
design like removing Lanes adding street
parking instead and developing retail
and housing and parking lots a built
environment that will get more people on
foot more drivers to slow down and will
save lives it's not a quick solution but
something we need to actually be
starting to move towards rather than
continuing to build the sprawling
development that we know is dangerous
this video is an adaptation of a vox.com
story by reporter Marin kogan local
officials and journalists have credited
her reporting for raising awareness
about pedestrian safety along this
deadly stretch of road I highly
recommend you check out her story that I
Linked In the description below thanks
so much for watching